the Mandalorian might be barely halfway
through its inaugural season but that
hasn't stopped baby Yoda from becoming
the subject of intense internet
speculation we've run across a couple of
theories that have us contemplative lis
stroking our chins and saying hmm
fascinating this is something to this
there could be these are the most
intriguing of them all if there's one
thing we can say with reasonable
certainty about Yoda species which
George Lucas famously insisted not being
named it's that they're pretty rare
other than Yoda and now the so-called
baby Yoda we've only ever seen one
yeah doll a female of the species who
was shown to be a member of the Jedi
High Council in Star Wars Episode one
The Phantom Menace the fact that all
three of these critters are force users
is provocative in and of itself which
we'll discuss more in a moment but many
fans have quite reasonably wondered if
baby Yoda could actually be Yoda son an
idea which we find to be unlikely the
thing about the Yoda secret love child
theory which is a combination of words
we never thought we'd say is that it
would take a serious leap of logic to
make it fit with the events of the
original trilogy
sure baby Yoda is 50 years old and
therefore would have been around when
Yoda was alive the Mandalorian
remember'd takes place five years after
the events of those films it's
conceivable that Yoda could have sent
his wee offspring away to protect him as
was done with the infants Luke and Leia
before the original trilogy's events but
it's a bit of a stretch to by that the
Jedi Master would never mention the
taught to Luke not even on his deathbed
now we find it more likely that there's
a difference though just as direct
connection to Yoda that baby Yoda is a
clone of the late Jedi Master this
theory is lent credence by the fact that
in the Mandalorians third episode the
clients employee dr. Pershing was seen
to be wearing a patch with an insignia
suspiciously similar to that worn by the
many many clones of Jango Fett seen in
episode 2 attack of the clones it sure
seems like that fact has to be setting
up something but if baby Yoda himself
isn't a clone perhaps it's setting up
something
else this is what was causing all the
putz
other than the fact that there aren't a
whole lot of them there's something else
we feel comfortable inferring about Yoda
species they appear to be natural force
users in the Mandalorians second episode
baby Yoda levitated a ferocious mutt
horn the size of a bus sure it took a
lot out of him but the point is that
we're pretty sure he wasn't taught this
ability the question then is just how
rare is this species hey here's another
one if they were so rare as to be say on
the verge of extinction doesn't it seem
likely that several parties on both
sides of the lightside dark side divide
would have an interest in preserving
them one fan theory states that baby
Yoda is in fact the last of his kind and
that he's not a clone but rather the
clients interest in the little guy is to
clone him this theory is bolstered by a
line the client spits at the hapless dr.
Pershing in the Mandalorians third
episode as mando eavesdrops on the
conversation in advance of his daring
rescue of baby Yoda extract the
necessary material and be done with it
Pershing then replies that someone it's
not crystal clear who quote explicitly
ordered us to bring it back alive which
of course raises a whole new set of
questions the most obvious being who is
he referring to unless that conversation
is a total red herring we find the clone
theory to be pretty credible but there
might also be something else going on
here stay with us here because this
theory is a bit silly even if it sounds
pretty Star Wars II on paper good chair
good chair nice lumbar support great
view of utter blackness if baby Yoda
isn't a clone then what kind of material
would the client be extracting and for
what purpose
well we know that Yoda had an insanely
high midi-chlorian count so it stands to
reason that even if baby Yoda is only
loosely related to the lay Jedi Master
the little guys count is probably in the
same range his genetic material then
perhaps even his blood might be of use
to a force sensitive being whose
connection to the force has been lost or
diminished or who is very near death or
both okay so you probably know who we're
talking about is it possible that the
unknown party who ordered the client to
bring baby Yoda back alive is
other than emperor palpatine the very
same big bad who was going to be
returning to vex our heroes and rise up
Skywalker could the little tyke in fact
be the key to his big comeback it sure
is a compelling theory but frankly we'll
be shocked if it's true not because it
doesn't make narrative sense it'd be
awesome for the Mandalorian to tie-in to
the rise of Skywalker in such a crazy
fashion we just don't think there's any
way that the two Productions could have
synched up well enough to make any
crossover possible let alone one that
would be so important to the movies
narrative having said that it's not
outside the realm of possibility
we know thanks to director Colin
Trevorrow that JJ abrams had the idea to
bring Palpatine back into the skywalker
saga sometime after September 2017 which
is when Trevor Rove departed the project
Disney CEO Bob Iger announced that the
mandalorian was in development in
November of that year and Jon Favreau
was introduced as the series writer and
showrunner in March 2018
Favreau didn't waste any time getting to
work by May of that year he told
multiple outlets that half of the
scripts for the first season of the
mandalorian had been completed this
means that sometime between the fall of
2017 and the spring of 2018 Fabri when
Abrams would have to have gotten
together and hammered out all of the
shared story elements of their
respective projects then they would have
needed to remain in contact making sure
that neither of them was stepping on the
other's toes all while keeping the whole
thing a total secret again this wouldn't
have been impossible but it sure would
have been difficult and nobody would
know this better than Favreau who
directed the first two Iron Man movies
and has appeared as happy Hogan in the
films of the intricately connected
Marvel Cinematic Universe ever since
we're going to go ahead and say that
baby Yoda is not likely to factor into
the story of rise of Skywalker at all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bells so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]